The Joe Biden administration has already done
so much that I want to spend time today focusing
on that, but we should talk about the inauguration,
which happened yesterday, it was notable in
that it was very different than past inaugurations
for a number of reasons.
It took place during a global hundred year
pandemic.
And so the crowd was very, very small and
the entire National Mall, which would often
be filled with people to different degrees,
depending on which inauguration we're talking
about.
As we know, the crowd size of inaugurations
has been a flashpoint in the past, empty with
flags.
Instead, the outgoing president wasn't there
for the first time in 152 years.
Donald Trump fleeing Washington, D.C. for
Palm Beach, Florida, early in the morning
yesterday.
But Joe Biden was sworn in.
There were no incidents of violence.
There were no arrests or unrest in the area,
just the new presidency.
And Vice President Kamala Harris being sworn
in here.
Supreme Court Justice Sonia Sotomayor does
mispronounce Carmela's name as Kamala.
No one's perfect.
I expect that there will be much of that in
the next few years.
Please raise your right hand and repeat after
me.
I, Kamala Harris, do solemnly swear.
I, Kamala Harris, solemnly swear that I will
support and defend the Constitution of the
United States, that I will support and defend
the Constitution against all enemies, foreign
and domestic, against all enemies, foreign
and domestic, that I will bear true faith
and allegiance to the same, that I will bear
true faith and allegiance.
That I take this obligation freely, that I
take this obligation freely without any mental
reservation or purpose of evasion, without
any mental reservation or purpose of evasion,
that I will well and faithfully discharge,
that I will well and faithfully discharge
the duties of the office on which I am about
to enter the duties of the office upon which
I am about to enter.
So help me God.
And then Joe Biden also sworn in by the chief
justice of the Supreme Court, John Roberts,
please raise your right hand and repeat after
me.
I, Joseph Robinette Biden Jr., do solemnly
swear.
Joseph Robinette Biden Jr. do solemnly swear
that I will faithfully execute, that I will
faithfully execute the office of president
of the United States, office of president
of the United States.
And will, to the best of my ability, well,
to the best of my ability, preserve, protect
and defend, preserve, protect and defend the
Constitution of the United States Constitution
of the United States.
So help you God.
So help me God.
Congratulations, Mr. President.
So there it is, Trump out, Biden in Biden
giving a speech focused on unity, the the
the pragmatic reality is there will likely
not be the unity Biden calls for, but Biden
calling for it, not mentioning Trump once,
but mentioning the big challenges that lie
ahead of the country for the country, including
starting to be respected again by the world,
dealing with the virus and more.
Here is Joe Biden talking about that.
I know, speaking of unity, can sound to some
like a foolish fantasy these days.
I know the forces that divide us are deep
and they are real, but I also know they are
not new.
Our history has been a constant struggle between
the American ideal that we are all are created
equal and the harsh, ugly reality that racism,
nativism, fear, demonization have long torn
us apart.
Biden directly attacking the deceptive and
pernicious disinformation that has become
standard during Trump in America, about which
during which we saw facts manufactured.
Every disagreement doesn't have to be a cause
for total war, and we must reject the culture
in which facts themselves are manipulated
and even manufactured.
Now, former Vice President Mike Pence at the
inauguration not clapping on that one and
during many others, and why would he?
Biden is pointing directly to him, not with
his finger, but with his words.
And it is Pence and Trump and their supporters
and media allies that did the manufacturing
of many of those so-called facts.
Joe Biden then telling the folks that did
not support him, that he will also be their
president and asking them to hear him out.
All those who supported our campaign, I'm
humbled by the faith you've placed in us to
all those who did not support us.
Let me say this.
Hear me out as we move forward.
Take a measure of me and my heart.
If you still disagree, so be it.
That's democracy.
That's America.
The right to dissent peaceably in the guardrails
of our republic is perhaps this nation's greatest
strength.
Yet here we clearly disagreement must not
lead to this union.
And I pledge this to you.
I will be a president for all Americans, all
Americans.
And then Joe Biden saying we will repair our
alliances.
Of course, the reason these alliances need
repair is that they were destroyed by the
Trump administration.
Biden doesn't say that, but it's certainly
implied.
We all understand the world is watching, watching
all of us today, so here's my message to those
beyond our borders.
America has been tested and we've come out
stronger for it.
We will repair our alliances and engage with
the world once again, not to be yesterday's
challenges, but today's and tomorrow's challenges.
So this was the right speech for the right
moment.
And very quickly, I mean, almost instantly,
in a sense, we shifted from the ceremonial
to the logistical and to getting things done.
There are so many things desperately needed
and shockingly overdue right now that there's
quite literally no time to bask in the afterglow
of the inauguration and the afterglow of the
fireworks, the literal afterglow, because
there's so much that needs to get done.
And that's exactly what I want to talk about
next.